academically never before had I thought
to apply to a private institution for
college that had not crossed my mind I
thought it was too far out of my reach
but Sam's really helped me build that
confidence
and chemical engineering the lab
instructor is Matt Klein and he has this
he lets you do hands-on projects and I
was actually on a group of guys and we
made some of this truck liner coating
and I mean that was pretty cool because
we got to see like the different
chemical reactions and like what
temperatures at work like the reactions
work best set
a lot of my classes are majority guys
but um you just can't be afraid and
having like going that you do have
confidence in yourself if you're willing
to work with them often enough they'll
be willing to work with you
the same program showed how caring and
how supportive the staff is here
especially in see mark and the other
thing was meeting actual faculty um
because they care they really do a lot
of them don't let you fall be like Paul
behind there they're willing to help so
that wasn't a bit of very important
factor and deciding to come here